at the west scotland community is like
we all seem to know somebody who has
covers
waterford is mirroring the covet
situation across ireland at the moment
extremely high vaccine uptake but
stubbornly high infection rates
local man tom gallaher nearly died from
the disease he spent 66 days in hospital
twice on a ventilator and icu before
being allowed home because if people
think that the vaccine is is the
full metal jacket like you know you have
total immunity but obviously you don't
you know why pity is the grandparents
who are still living at home who are
very sick of getting these things of
getting this worse
you know because i mean it's the
vulnerable people who are still doing
sleep people who have underlying
ailments you know
in a city famous for its walls the
vaccine hasn't been a barrier to high
infection rates
a pretty staggering
99.5 percent of all adults over the age
of 18 here in waterford are now fully
vaccinated that's the highest
vaccination rate in ireland and thought
to be among the highest anywhere in the
world despite this county watford
currently has the highest covalent
infection rate in the country so why
most agree there's a range of factors at
work there was already a high level of
the delta variant in ireland before the
vaccine rollout picked up pace others
point to high levels of travel between
ireland and the uk which has a much
higher incidence of covert and as
restrictions have fallen away
behavioural scientists say there's been
a perceivable change in people's
attitude to taking risks
what's happened is restrictions of ease
has been a gradual increase in social
activity coupled with a decrease in
people taking day-to-day mitigation
behaviors like keeping two meters from
each other and wearing masks
science hasn't failed according to well
scientists immunologists say the
vaccines were never meant to eliminate
infections and are performing a vital
role function of a vaccine is to prevent
illness and death that's the primary
goal and the vaccines are holding up
it's great without the vaccines ireland
would be in a full lockdown now because
the delta is so transmittable the
hospitals will be full of covert
patients and all the evidence supports
that as long as the vaccine suppresses
hospital and especially intensive care
admissions the irish government says it
has no plans to bring back restrictions
but it won't rule it out either
stephen murphy sky news in waterford